this morning some 17 million people
across Central and Northern California
are under flood watches ahead of a
massive storm system another so-called
atmospheric river is likely to drench
the region tonight and into the weekend
it could bring dangerous amounts of rain
to most of the places that are now
buried in heavy snow and that could lead
to widespread flooding Carter Evans is
in the Sierra Nevada town of Truckee
California Carter good morning
good morning Vlad as you can see there
is already a tremendous amount of snow
on the ground we've actually packed it
down here it is piled well overhead in
some areas and there's going to be a lot
more of it but this storm is also
bringing warmer temperatures it'll be in
the mid 30s when it hits here this
evening that could mean rain in some
areas and melting lots of snow before it
all turns to ice again
on Wednesday a new layer of snow covered
the Lake Tahoe area prompting road
closures we sledded in all the all of
the the gasoline on a toboggan
many residence homes and cars have been
trapped on all sides by snow that just
keeps piling higher
people in Mountain communities across
California have spent weeks with shovels
in hand I'm gonna get three to five
inches five to eight and then five to
eight turned into a foot or more every
you know every 12 hours and while
elevated communities could see several
more feet many more Californians are
under flood watches these Bay Area
residents have been busy filling
sandbags
in Southern California a growing number
of grim discoveries the San Bernardino
County Sheriff's Office says at least
one person was killed by the previous
storm while 11 others were found dead
during welfare checks even after two
weeks people here are struggling
probably about a million cubic yards
today it's it's a daunting task
now the Sierra snowpack is like a frozen
Reservoir that slowly melts and provides
water to the region but now we've got
this war rain coming and that could
cause a lot of it to melt now that is
why there is so much concern now that it
could cause flooding Downstream in lower
line areas Tony
Carter thank you very much